since we're on that topic um this goes along
with that uh do we need to keep the feast days
today why or why not no we don't need to keep
the feast days the feast days were fulfilled
in christ now there's one feast day not
yet fulfilled the feast of tabernacles
but the feast days are to be studied because
they have lessons for us let me say that again
the feast days are to be studied all the
sacrificial offerings are to be studied
they presented in pictorial form i would use the
word pictorial the gospel christ was teaching
the israelites the gospel he was dealing with
a nation of or a group of people who had been
thoroughly egyptianized as a matter of fact if
you read ezekiel chapter 20 prior to bringing
them out god told them whatever your false gods
the fire not yourselves with the idols of egypt
but they rebelled against me and would not hearken
unto me they did not every man cast away his idols
neither did they forsake the idols of egypt
god is saying while they were in egypt they
held onto their gods and i wanted to destroy them
in egypt but i brought them out because i made a
promise to abraham and i didn't want i did not
want to look back before the nations and so they
were egyptianized they always wanted to go back
god had to find a kindergarten where you know in
kindergarten always pictures on the walls god had
to find a simple way to explain salvation abraham
didn't need that noah didn't need that methuselah
didn't shem didn't they didn't enoch didn't
but these egyptianized israelites they needed
it the sacrificial system must be studied thy
way or lord is in the sanctuary we must study the
sacrifices but don't go killing animals because
if you keep any of the feasts you have to carry
out the sacrifices associated with that feast
all right
you